Thawne?
Direct from Earth One
Do you like my face?
It's the face you are wearing when I became the Flash. I thought I'd put it on again, you know
for old times sake plus
handsome. I watched you die. Or did you?
Time travel Barry.
So very confusing I always seem to be saying that to you, don't I?
[grunt] Ugh
Go on, end it.
End it!
What's stopping you?
Ah, I forgot Barry Allen is above killing. Isn't that right?
Get out of here.
I wonder what face I'll be wearing next time we meet, Flash.
Can't wait.
[panting]
Gideon. Yes Professor Thawne?
Where the hell am I?
[gun shots]
He's being erased from existence
So, uh what should we call this brave new world that you've whipped up for us, I was thinking
Flashpoint.
There we go.
Things are back to how they should be. Well for me anyway.
For you.
[chuckles]
Well. I guess you'll just have to wait and find out.
[Black Flash roar]
No.
[grunt] Ugh.
[Black Flash roars]
NOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
Hey everybody! So far away, the biggest question
I got after the big crossover episode was: How is it that earth one Reverse-Flash from Season 1 is back
harassing Barry.
But they're just a couple key pieces of information that the TV show has not told you yet that
explains how he can still be alive, given the events of Season 1,2,3 of the Flash and Season 2 of Legends of Tomorrow
because we've seen him die a number of times.
But if you are finding me for the first time, be sure to subscribe
to get everything we're also doing a new round of the flash ring giveaway that I'll explain at the end of the video too.
So in order to understand how Reverse Flash and time-travel works
You need to know two real big things. One: that they've never fully explained the rules of time-travel in the Arrowverse and
Two: When speedsters die, without fail they go back into the Speed Force as pure energy.
No matter how they die they go back into the Speed Force. So like when you see the Reverse Flash being vaporized
here at the end of Season 1 and then later during Legends of Tomorrow Season 2, he's actually being sucked up into the Speed Force.
So just remember that as we go through his timeline here.
So I'll explain what happened to him along the way.
When Matt Letcher went on Legends of Tomorrow last season, he actually said something funny
he's like don't hold them to the fire too much on the rules of time-travel.
He didn't say in quite so many words
but he was basically saying that the Legends of Tomorrow writers were gonna mess around with the Reverse-Flash character, and they weren't gonna worry
too much about what was going on with him on the Flash TV show and the same thing
vice-versa for the Flash writers. The Flash writers whenever they did Reverse Flash again wouldn't have to pay too much attention
to what Legends of Tomorrow did with the character. Which is a little frustrating
but it actually does work out if you just remember those two rules that I talked about.
Primarily that when speedsters die, whether they're evil, they're good speedsters
they just get sucked back up into the Speed Force as pure energy. So every time the Reverse Flash dies
he just goes up into the Speed Force
until he can escape again. What that means is, is that the reverse flash that we saw during the course o Legends of Tomorrow
Season Two is a completely different version of the character.
So what happens is, is at the end of Season 1 this version of the Reverse Flash dies. He gets
sucked back up into the Speed Force. When we get to Season Two and we see him port in looking for Barry,
it's actually a younger version of the character who hasn't gone through the events of Season One yet.
He doesn't know where Barry lives in the timeline, and he's just looking for him.
He finds him, then at the end of that episode
Barry throws him back into the future so that in his own future he can come back to the night that he killed
Barry's mother do that and set off the events of Season One. So that all goes according to plan
but then you get to the end of Season Two and Barry goes back to create
Flashpoint. So the version that he's
grabbing out of the timeline and creating Flashpoint with is the version that we saw in Season Two. So by this point we're on a
completely different iteration of the character and the Season One version of the Reverse Flash is still stuck in the Speed Force as pure energy.
When they fix Flashpoint, the second version of Eobard Thawne tells Barry that everything's fine for me
but you're just gonna have to wait and see, which was more of a teaser for Savitar than anything else. So then he goes off
to Legends of Tomorrow.
But he reveals that he's actually a Time Remnant version of the character who should have been erased when Eddie killed himself.
So this is where they're trying to sew up their logic. He's a time remnant, shouldn't exist. Black Flash
eventually catches up with him, kills him
and he gets sucked back up into the Speed Force.
So the reason why this is red instead of white, is because it's a completely different version of the character.
So the thing about the Reverse Flash and the thing about time-travel is that it takes a while for
changes to stick, so when the Reverse Flash says that: he's always one step ahead,
he's literally one step ahead of time waves.
But here's the thing to remember, the writers from each of the different shows don't follow each other's rules a hundred percent.
So when they brought back this version of the Reverse Flash
and he pretty much said: I'm the one from Season 1, Barry's like: I saw you die.
So just confirming which version it is. It's basically the Flash writers saying that that version that you saw on Legends of Tomorrow is a
completely different iteration of the character. So it's sort of the writers room using the vagaries of the way they've defined the rules of
time-travel in that they have not defined any of the rules and
sweeping a lot of the Legends of Tomorrow stuff under the rug, like we saw him die was a big moment on TV but
we're not gonna bring that version of the character back.
That pretty much confirms that the next time we see Matt Lecher come back and play Eobard Thawne,
he'll be a different version than we've seen before. But a lot of that just depends on where he comes from, and how much
information he has. Usually that's how you chart the Reverse Flashes timeline. Is what does he remember?
What does he know about Barry?
But based on what he said at the end of the episode it confirms that the next time we see
Reverse Flash it will be this version of the character just wearing a different face.
And I think that might have something to do with the actors in real life. Like Tom Cavanagh plays him every once in a while
and it's really cool.
But usually it helps to have another version of the character, so we might wind up with a situation where he's either
masquerading as Barry or he's masquerading as another evil speedster. Like we could get Max Mercury,
it could be the Reverse Flash wearing his face. The writers
and the producers
haven't said anything about the next time they're gonna bring him back. It might be towards the end of the Season because there's the whole
Tornado twins thing that happened during the crossover which I'll do a separate video for and that seems like it's going to come back around
at the very end of the season. So there were just a couple things that happened during these crossover episodes where they're teasing
plot points that they won't pay off till future seasons or the very very end of this season.
So hopefully that explains a little bit about how this version of the Reverse Flash can still be alive and Eddie is still dead. A lot
of you were asking when the Black Flash is going to come back.
I'm not expecting him to come back until we get a lot more speedster type stories
and that doesn't seem like it's gonna be a thing until next season and future seasons after that.
There is a new round of that flash ring giveaway. All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber,
leave a comment on this video. Congratulations to the winner from my Titans video Infinity Jay.
Please private message me so I can get your contact details. You can click here for that Titan Season One Robin teaser
and you can click here for my new Infinity War video. Thank you so much for watching, everybody stay awesome! I'll see you guys tonight.